et notre mission qu'on va demander
maintenant à nos jeunes qui sont avec
nous sur ce plateau il ya manel il ya
axel je vous ai présenté il ya quelques
minutes
ils sont là pour nous dire un petit plus
qui disent qu'il est tout ce qui les
énerve ce qui leur plaît en l'occurrence
manel tu voulais nous parlait ce matin
de domotique c'est quoi la domotique
c'est celle usage nouveau que l'on fait
des appareils domestiques notamment à
les contrôler à distance d'accord jusque
là on a tout compris contre la distance
axel marilyn bon j'en ai un petit peu
donc attention je suis envahie à mazel
comment ça marche
ben on peut les contrôler avec par
exemple un téléphone c'est en fait c'est
des robes on peut dire ouais on peut
dire que iad électronique
oui que c'est plutôt électroniques
j'arrête là pour la rime parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de robotique dans cette
histoire je crois que si je dis par
exemple qu'il en existe notamment sur
certains aspirateurs
oui parce qu'on les voit et qu'on en a
beaucoup entendu parler de ces
aspirateurs un peu peur automatique
finalement c'est ça ou pas oui
exactement
ouais c'est les aspirateurs robots qui
font le travail d'un aspirateur manuel
sans l'aide des d'un être humain et il
aspire tout ça alors ça concerne aussi
d'autres objets oui comme les cafés
tiers les on pourra fermer nos volets
les lumières le chauffage exactement
mais oui bien sûr qu'en claquant de joie
ça c'est du jeu claque des doigts manel
et on continue tu trouve ça bien c'est
super franchement j'aimerais bien avoir
en plus ça coûte pas cher ouais ouais
alors ce coûte pas cher et relatifs à
mais ça coûte voilà ça coûte
pourquoi tu trouve ça bien hormis le
fait que ça coûte pas cher selon toi et
que finalement ce grand service
on n'a plus besoin de rien faire on fait
juste on claque des doigts comme vous
dites est fait et après on est
tranquille d'accord est quand même
nécessaire d'avoir un petit téléphone au
minimum par exemple pour la domotique
dont tu nous parlais tout à l'heure m à
ses branches est assez branché téléphone
oui faudrait un téléphone en tout cas à
la pointe comme pour pouvoir bien le
contrôle et bien contrôler l'appareil
pour l'instant la maison papa soir bon
il ya quand même quelques inconvénients
et oui mais alors ça et ça c'est ça
c'est un modèle pour nous un avec
marilyn parce que c'est vrai que quand
on pose une question fermée dans répond
oui ou non donc alors quelles sont ses
inconvénients
voilà m'avait pas déjà ça va nous rendre
fainéants parce que bon jour là aux gens
comment c'est pas notre genre à les
masser mozart ouais d'accord soldate
pour la moindre tâche vous la moindre
miette
on va vouloir vraiment utiliser
l'aspirateur par exemple au lieu de le
faire nous mêmes
évidemment ça va nous rendre fainéant
comme j'ai dit il faut un téléphone à la
pointe comme je les ai dit tout à
l'heure et ça peut marginaliser une
partie de la population notamment les
personnes âgées car en fin de compte
c'est qu'ils ont le plus besoin jamais
de dire mais avec l'électronique y la
majorité ne comprennent pas trop comment
ça fonctionne et ils peuvent pas trop
l'utiliser en fait tampon avec des
copains et des copines de la domotique
ce changement absolument pas mais alors
pourquoi tu as voulu nous en parler
c'est ce qui s'est passé s'est trouvée
parce que toi c'était voilà quelque
chose qui était branché oui voilà
exactement déjà le robot automatique
j'aimerais trop en avoir un c'est pour
ça que moi je me suis dit tiens je vais
parler de l'eau robots et pourquoi pas
par l'idh la domotique en général à
bosser bien c'est bien je suis sûr qu
entre copains et copines tous les deux
vous parlez plus des influenceurs sur
sur les réseaux sociaux à l'instar
grammer vous savez ce que c'est oui
allez c'est quoi axel mais ce que ouais
qui poste des chaussures instagram way
qui influencent simplement
qui peut influencer en tout cas on a
rencontré justement un influent sur vous
en avez dans votre école au lycée jean
marc boivin des gens qui sont à fond sur
instagram
qu'est-ce que tu postes comme photo mais
on va rencontrer neuf personnes de la
région qui s'est lancé sur le créneau de
la mode
pour lui c'est un petit peu la fashion
week au quotidien regarder qu'une
renault avec axel pour parler notamment
de son coup de coeur pour axel ce sera
la fin de l'argent liquide à l'est a
tout de suite
il nous a donné rendez vous dans une
usine abandonnée
il s'est levé anthony 32 ans ce
dijonnais n'est pas un mannequin
professionnel et pourtant à le regarder
c'est tout comme les shootings il les
enchaîne mais aucun ne se ressemble
paré regard de tout côté ce que je
cherche surtout à mettre en avant c'est
le t-shirt qui est juste issue de
whitburn vous êtes noir qu'elle
affectionne particulièrement
je crois que le lieu en fait se prêtait
absolument à la tenue en fait puis
j'aime bien aussi le côté un pur bex
côté un peu havrais fait mère sache trop
ça hyper intéressant anthony ne vous dit
peut-être rien et pourtant il est suivi
par près de 25 mille internautes sur son
compte instagram
en fait il est ce qu'on appelle un
influenceur autrement dit c'est lui qui
conseille ses abonnés aient pu influer
sur leurs achats mode
mon but c'est vraiment de proposer des
gros coups de coeur en fête et les
produits qui m'intéresse le plus
donc j'aime bien mettre en avant les
petites marques en fait qu'ils sont en
train de se créer de se lancer sur le
marché et aussi les marques qui ont une
valeur éthique et qui sont éco
responsable des marques avec lyon toni
sinde collaboration bien souvent c'est
elle qui le démarche et lui envoie
directement les produits à la maison
donc là c'est la petite surprise le
petit short ce tee shirts et cadeaux
contre une publication
quand on est influenceurs c'est un peu
noël toutes les semaines je sois une
dotation de produits parce qu'il ya 90 %
des cas le cas et puis à côté on me
propose aussi de temps en temps des
rémunérations puis la communauté grand
forcément plus la rémunération risque
d'être élevée et plus interactions sont
élevées également et plus la
rémunération peut monter en termes de
salaires et ça peut aller de 50 euros la
photo à plusieurs milliers d'euros pour
un shooting
mais le jeune homme n'a pas la folie des
grandeurs considérant son job
d'influenceurs comme un complément
d'activité son image il là mais aussi
aux services d'événements locaux
ce dirigeant d'une agence de
communication développe un nouveau
concept d'apéro secret anthony fait
partie des dix instagram heures
sélectionnés pour promouvoir ces
événements
pour moi ça a plus d'impact en fait
qu'une parution presse par exemple avec
nos dix influenceurs on peut avoir en
une soirée
fin mai mme en quelques heures
puis 200 milles vue c'est énorme c'est
une norme chose qu une gazette locale
n'était pas rien qu'à dijon on compte
pas moins d'une dizaine d' influence or
ils vous l'aurez compris rayonne bien
au-delà de la bourgade
manel axel vous suivez ces influenceurs
c'est instagram heures comme on dit non
plus pas beaucoup non ça nous rassure un
peu
vous avez bien compris qu'il y avait
quelque chose derrière un contre push
mais bien évidemment bien évidemment là
on le voit un petit peu dans ce
reportage
il n'est pas vraiment question d'argent
mais par contre des chances de
marchandises c'est en fait de la pub
déguisée bien souvent voilà en sachant
que sur un salaire il ya aussi des
choses qui cartonne beaucoup beaucoup
c'est la cuisine les plats de cuisine ça
ça cartonne énormément ce casque de
moins de cartonner axel c'est la fin de
l'argent liquide
l'état n'a envie de nous en parler ce
matin et voilà ça veut dire quoi pour
toi la fin de l'argent liquide axel en
fait on sait que depuis toujours les
artistes et vendeurs des rues vivent
grâce à la monnaie amassés auprès des
passants ouais mais avec la disparition
progressive du visage de l'argent
liquide mais il faut s'adapter et du
coup beaucoup ont déjà fait comme par
exemple le jeune chanteuse de rue sur
lot campbell elle adopté avec un lecteur
de cartes sans contact à l'ombre du
doigt la grande route de londres ça
c'est quand même assez délirant marilyn
vous que vous allez nous parler musique
d'ici la fin de cette émission avec un
groupe régional c'est à dire qu' il n'y
a plus la petite gamelle il avait
déclaré à un chapeau tout simplement et
comme disait accès tout à fait il ya un
petit lecteur de cartes et on passe avec
son smartphone ou sa carte n'est pas
fait on laisse des sous c'est ça mais
c'est plutôt impressionnant parce que 5
à 10% de ses revenus ne revienne plus de
monnaie donc jeté dans un coup de
guitare ouais mais de paiement effectué
là dessus d'accord donc ça se passe en
angleterre
ça veut dire que allez je vais peut-être
me lancer au risque de paraître un peu
un peu étrange
ça veut dire que si on traverse la
manche il ya un peu moins d'argent
liquide que chez nous on peut dire ça
comme ça oui tout à fait au royaume uni
sont vraiment
or au vent le mien c'est impressionnant
on attend sur un oui selon moi oui parce
qu'il ya aussi un rapport du trésor qui
a été publié cette année qui montre que
la peur de paiement en liquide est tombé
62 % en 2006 à 40 % en 2016 donc c'est
une baisse qui est assez importante
quand même et en plus le gouvernement il
encourage le mouvement c'est pour ça que
ça simplement anglais je peux le
gouvernement anglais bien sûr et
français aussi du coup le anglais
principalement parce que il est en effet
interdit aux commerçants de faire payer
des frais supplémentaires pour ceux qui
utilisent des cartes
ils sont fous ces anglais a dit oui
croyable on est loin du brics il a quand
même
alors allez on va revenir chez nous en
france et ce qui nous intéressait
pourquoi pas en bourgogne franche comté
accède selon toi l'argent liquide en
france laurent france c'est pareil en
fait parce que les distributeurs sont en
train de disparaître petit à petit parce
qu'il coûte beaucoup trop cher pour les
banques
donc ils ne sont plus rentables de même
pour les chèques qui ont connu un grand
grand grand succès dans les années 70
mais qui tendent eux aussi à disparaître
du fait qu'ils sont très faciles à
falsifier et du coup les banques les
magasins et refuse ouais et tu en penses
quoi toi bats je pense que d'un côté ce
une bonne chose parce que c'est très
pratique on alors comme vous dites
rarement du liquide sur soi
du coup c'est plutôt et puis tu de plus
en plus maintenant
c'était dématérialisée mais l'envié
d'aider effet plus négatif
bah oui donc je pense c'est une bonne
chose pour ça mais pour le côté négatif
c'est que les personnes âgées vont avoir
beaucoup de mal à s'adapter parce que
c'est quand même moderne il faut avoir
bons mâles paiement sans contact
beaucoup de gens nous mais ouais vous
avez une vision des personnes âgées
samba j'ai un gros c'est leur avis et
puis également pour les personnes qui
sont en bas sdf parce qu'ils n'auront
pas du coup des lecteurs sans contact je
pense et du coup nous ne recevons plus
un sentiment bon c'est cela je crois que
je crois que c'est la morale de
l'histoire
merci axel pour ce coup de gueule coeur
t'en parle franchement avec tes copains
aussi de tout ça un petit peu quand même
ouais parce que ça nous concerne on
commence à voir la joie devant des
cartes bancaires et puis tout certains
l'argent de poche j'ai une carte
bancaire maintenant j'ai peur